over the last month much to the Chagrin
of my increasingly impatient wife I've
dedicated every waking moment to
exploring the rich and wondrous world of
Full Metal Alchemist it's one of the
most widely celebrated animated
properties to have ever come out of
Japan and I love it it's got colorful
characters great world building a
gripping mystery some hard-stopping
action and the perfect ending if it
wasn't for the fact that I know my wife
would kill me I'd read it again here and
now but my friends do not worry for I do
not need to risk my life I have found a
loophole while I can sit down and watch
and read the series again like I want to
what I can do is mindlessly consume
brand new content surrounding arakawa's
magnum opus and wouldn't you know it
there's a brand new Trilogy of films
that are waiting for me they've been
released over the last five years and
cover the whole story oh okay is that
um
so it would appear to be the case that
this film Trilogy for Fullmetal
Alchemist is
live action
[Music]
how bad could it be right well in the
past I've been pretty harsh on live
action adaptations and beloved animated
properties but look the last thing I
want to do is spend time with my family
I mean uh say goodbye to Full Metal
Alchemist yeah that's what I meant so
let's give this a fair shot and who
knows it might be an incredible
adaptation or one of the worst things my
eyeballs and mind have ever endured on
this hell skin oh my God was that was
that foreshadowing couldn't be
regardless I mean it's not impossible to
improve upon an idea when switching
mediums it just needs to be done right
so let's see if this first film adapts
the material in an appropriate way
entitled Fullmetal Alchemist this first
film was released on the 1st of December
2017 and currently sits with a rather
lopsided Rotten Tomatoes score with an
awful rough and rotten looking 28 from
critics and to significantly more
impressive and fresh 71 from General
audiences and you know what sometimes
the critics are wrong sometimes it's a
great movie that gets a bad rap so I'm
willing to suspend my expectations going
with an open mind end
[Music]
full metal Alchemist 2017. so this one
is a real Barrel laughs and I mean that
in both a good and a bad way each film
generally covers one third of the
mainline story with this first
installment covering the material up to
Mustang vs lust one of the best scenes
in the series I think and needless to
say my expectations went through the
roof
oh God damn it two hours later I have
seen things I wish I never saw and while
there are of course elements from this
that I did enjoy for one reason or
another there is also an unbelievably
long list of things wrong with this film
sold so very long and looking at the
Rotten Tomatoes score for the other
films in this Trilogy it seems like it's
kind of all downhill from here so let's
have some fun and try to learn something
along the way from this shared trauma
bonding experience something I should
make clear however at this point is that
I'm convinced that live action while it
has yielded truly awful adaptations from
The Animated World I don't think it
necessarily needs to be that way and
what's more is I genuinely believe that
while animation has obvious advantages
over live action that I will get into
later on in this video it also has
disadvantages remember Equivalent
Exchange here if there are positives
there are likely negatives associated
with it too and as I said I will
absolutely be getting into those in
areas where this film shines sell them
as those moments might be but enough
Preamble let's start the
well that was fast and honestly I wasn't
expecting to see this aspect of the
story so soon a part that wasn't
revealed until much later to be shown up
front to us like this is kind of
disarming and while I'm sure a manga
purist might be upset by this change
truth be told at this point in the story
less than two minutes in I was happy the
director decided to rearrange the order
of events presented to us because manga
and film are extremely different mediums
in the manga the very first page
demonstrates the key event that defines
the entire Journey at and I'll go on
together across these 27 volumes of
manga it's shocking it's graphic it
grabs your attention which is important
when the rest of the story isn't written
and you need to entice people to buy
more chapters later on however with a
film once the ticket is paid for or the
film is streamed or whatever they pretty
much have you unless the film turns out
to be incredibly boring and weird and oh
my God I'm getting ahead of myself but
at first glance despite the changes made
it's abundantly clear that a ton of work
has gone into the cinematography costume
design makeup and set design in order to
bring this story to life and I must say
despite the poorly done blonde hair and
the two Japanese children being a little
awkward I think their approach to
conveying what happened during the human
transmutation scene and the opening
credits was very impressive for
production that clearly wasn't as well
funded compared to other mainstream
Blockbusters despite this however the
film sort of begins to trip over its own
lofty ambition as the runtime trickles
on by approaching its own absolutely
baffling conclusions but we gotta save
that for later
[Music]
foreign
God that hair looks truly horrendous
like a cosplay straight out of Comic-Con
or something far more local okay so this
is minor but I think it's the first sign
that a certain level of care wasn't
taken with this movie script after the
first scene it's clear the director
turned what was the first page into the
first 10 minutes or so of the film
revealing aspects of the story that
don't take shape until much later in the
original run and the issue here is that
the film never bonded us to the
characters and while this thing that
happened to them is awful it's not
nearly as effective at tugging on our
heartstrings than it otherwise could
have been the manga despite opening with
that first page the rest of the first
chapter and indeed the second one
demonstrates Edward and Allen all of
their glory and slowly feeds us
information about their past never
outright stating much but instead
insinuating it through subtext and by
the time we eventually see the fabled
event that took everything away from
them it breaks us and bonds us to them
all the more because we know them in in
this scene a couple of kids go surfing
through a magic Whirlpool I don't know
we don't know these kids either and in
this scene that follows it in the future
the action scene is much more fun than I
expected albeit still sort of cartoonish
which is a trend for this live-action
film ironically enough but it just
doesn't even begin to approach the same
level of emotional weight that the
animated and Illustrated versions
provided there are some genuinely well
shot and realized action set pieces like
Ed manifesting a spear around his hand
but outside of that it's incredibly
awkward looking
this is where the cracks really start to
show visually and trust me there's a ton
more that are far worse than this we're
still only at the intro of the film and
yet this is another aspect that I think
highlights the shortcomings of live
action yet again unfortunately and
honestly it didn't need to be this way
last month myself and my team worked on
a comprehensive multi-hour review for
HBO series The Last of Us this was a
series tasked with adapting the story
from one of the most beloved and popular
video games of all time and while there
were sci-fi elements to it the live
action adaptation leaned into what makes
life action effective instead of
remaining a one-to-one with the Game
Source material and that I think is the
key and the sign of a great director and
writer when it comes to adapting
animated material keep the spirit the
same but change the packaging and
presentation to better suit the medium
you're working with however with
Fullmetal Alchemist 2017 instead of
Leaning into the dark and more realistic
nature of the series it instead decided
to focus on what made the series
appealing in Manga and Anime form
resulting in some of the most
cringe-inducing scenes that have made me
want to crawl into my own anus
oh
this is awful
[Music]
and who is this for in my country this
is given an age rating of 15s why have
you decided to make a live action
adaptation of a cartoon and write your
characters for this live action series
like cartoon characters and it's not a
cartoon it's anime what's the point in
making it live action it is the single
most cringe-worthy approach you could
take I mean my God you might have
noticed that I've not yet spoken about
Al by the way well that's because he
looks like a video game character and
hilariously isn't in this film very much
compared to the manga simply because I
assume it was too expensive resulting in
a severe lack of emotional Chemistry
Between the lead actor playing Ed and
the CGI Al character and so to remedy
this lack of emotional chemistry back
and forth between Edward and Al and to
have someone for Edward to talk to more
regularly we get more Winery
ah so far in this film all we've seen is
the transmutation scene we fought all
for the cornello minus all the parts of
the story that made it emotionally
meaningful to the characters and now we
get our first meeting between Edward
that looks like he's wearing a truly
awful wig and Mustang who actually looks
kind of great and as a fan of Ron myself
I regret to inform you all that my bad
writing senses were a tingling when
watching this scene there's nothing
silly visually to look at but man the
dialogue is clunky and because I know
where this story is going or at least I
think I do I know that all this dialogue
is here to replace events that otherwise
would show us what is instead being told
to us in the manga we came to learn of
Ed and Al's current situation during a
moment where they were able to teach a
young girl Rose how to stand up and push
forth for a better tomorrow for herself
no such scene takes place or replaces
that one instead we get an action scene
with cornello that ultimately tells us
nothing Beyond offering some mindless
action and introducing us to the
Philosopher's Stone all in all this
exchange between Edward and Mustang is a
poorly written scene if you're not
familiar with the original material but
as someone who is familiar with it it's
quite frustrating and disheartening to
know that I won't get to see any of the
material that you know is used to reveal
this information so many lines that were
once so effective as subtexts are now
being replaced with direct and explicit
lines that carry absolutely no emotional
weight but who cares about that because
that casting for Hughes is frighteningly
accurate like holy [__] it's like they
3D printed a living human being based on
hughes's exact specifications it's
surreal also why is Hawkeye's wig better
than Edward's wig why does he look like
the worst dressed person in the film
he's the lead actor and that's including
the weird immersion breaking alphons we
have on our hands too
so much of this film either feels
frantically fast because it's cramming
so many different plot lines together or
extremely boring because they are
talking Exposition at us or is
unintentionally hilarious because it's a
live action film that doesn't want to be
anything other than a cartoon at times
and really I think a big part of this
film's issue is that while it's clear
and unreasonable amount of work and
passion had gone into it I think it was
that reverence for the source material
and desire to both capture the magic
that paved the way for so many of these
seemingly perplexing decisions to be
made in the first place and on top of
that because this is only adapting the
material up to Lost versus Mustang they
needed to figure out a way to write a
story with some sort of emotional
resolution which spoiler alert doesn't
happen
God I hate this movie but I love that
dog god he's cute oh oh wait uh a cute
innocent girl adorable dog I want to
make my friend this means it's show
Tucker time
ladies and gentlemen I present to you
all the image that convinced me to pick
up the film in the first place and let
me tell you I did not regret it this is
one of the funniest images I've seen in
a long time it's it's like a meme
template built into the movie
unintentionally it's perfect but this
scene and section is where the wheels
really start to come off the wagon and
things get exceptionally silly so
typically when you adapt a work like
this which spans 27 volumes of manga
it's advisable to try to cut as much
content as you can while maintaining the
spirit of the property at hand what this
show does from this point is combine a
ton of scenes together do none of them
correctly along with and this really
surprised me elements from the 2003
anime 2 just for fun I guess like the
show Tucker scene as you can see didn't
exactly strike the same fear into my
soul as the original did but in addition
to that they make show Tucker one of the
main villains of the story all the while
combining his section with the Dr Marco
introduction scene only in this one lost
kills him they also combine it with some
elements from our first encounter with
Barry the chopper and of course lab
number five towards the end one of my
favorite sections does this approach
work absolutely not you must be joking
but check this out
so look I'm not going to beat around the
bush here this film is really boring in
the second act so let's skip to the
parts that I actually want to talk about
where one of the most terrible choices
for an ending occurs I can get past the
constant rearranging of scenes I can
deal with the emotion not really being
there I can even get on board with these
sleep paralysis demons that look like
they were made with all the same care as
the 1998 Godzilla movie what I cannot
accept is a truly horrific
misunderstanding and misrepresentation
and mutilation of what was one of my
favorite characters in the entire series
and my favorite scene in the entire
story they do Mustang so dirty in this
film and while his cool fire scenes
aren't nearly as cool as the anime or
Manga the problem I have isn't actually
anything to do with the visuals if you'd
believe it but to catch you all up on
what's happened in the movie Tucker is
freed because 2003 anime exists and we
need a villain that doesn't just show up
out of nowhere at the end and Al have
fought and Al says some truly out of
character things to his brother that he
otherwise would never have done in the
manga also Ed fights back another thing
I don't think he'd do they get back on
the same page Hughes is killed and
Mustang is framed instead of Maria and
that part is important so at present
Mustang is cornered on one side he's
facing Maria Ross as well as a bunch of
armed soldiers on her side and on the
other is Edward and Co so what does
Mustang decide to do
[Music]
this is so dumb this is literally every
Soldier involves Q to fill this guy with
lead he's given them every reason to so
why aren't they shooting well I'll tell
you because the plot doesn't call for it
and instead gives him enough time to
reveal to everyone that Envy is
disguised as Maria Ross which only
brings to the Forefront how the
homunculi are extremely underutilized
and unexplored by this point we've only
seen one scene with them alone together
or talking and it only served the
purpose of highlighting Envy's power in
the first place for this very scene
furthermore for the monkey light to make
a mistake like this one Envy makes it
really devalues the sort of conspiracies
they were capable of in the original
story I can't appreciate how tough it is
to create one film based on one third of
a story specifically because unlike most
other long manga this doesn't have arcs
it's one long continuous story but man
at least try to keep it somewhat
consistent
foreign
keep doing this for as long as you want
all right so lost stabs Mustang Alphonse
is the Damsel in Distress because it's
way too expensive to have him in the
film that much and Tucker is holding him
hostage until lost kills Tucker
why though
[Music]
let me tell you all the story of how
this film fundamentally ruined and
didn't understand the basic message
behind Mustang's Revenge story in the
manga you see
surrounding cubes
as dang being the one that was framed
arakawa decided to frame it on his
subordinate Maria Ross by doing so it
created the opportunity for a load more
mystery and shock surrounding Mustang's
application of force supposedly taking
her down segwaying that part of his
story into killing lust for defense of
others was one thing but he was never
outright murderous in those scenes even
when we were misdirected by the plot
itself I knew he'd never do something
like that until finally the twisted and
winding path these characters are
dragged down brings him face to face
with the killer of his best friend and
this is where Mustang snaps obviously
it's awesome to see Mustang exactly the
same sort of Revenge we all collectively
want as a reader but Hawkeye reminds him
of who he is Sky reminds him that going
down this path is one he can never truly
come back from if he goes through with
killing Envy so cold-heartedly and the
final message of this section is despite
having all the reasons in the world to
hate Envy Mustang chooses to to do the
right thing he chooses to be the best of
himself he chooses not to be ruled by
heian to instead leave Envy as a blob on
the floor it's my favorite part of the
entire story but this film says [__] it
and just has Mustang killed both lost
and envy for the lulls like what's even
the point of the character now
thematically he's an entirely vapid
caricature of the original that lacks
any and all of the emotional messaging
behind the entity that he's based on out
of all the atrocious decisions made in
this film of which there are a dizzying
amount this is by far the most egregious
it entirely misses the point of the
character and in an effort to
efficiently go through the material of
the original manga in this film The only
thing they succeeded in being efficient
with is assassinating Mustang's
character
so yeah that's the first film and
supposedly the best one pray for me
Fullmetal Alchemist the Revenge of Scar
due to what I can only assume was an
outstanding box office performance from
the first film in 2017 it appears the
powers that be saw it fit to Grant its
sequel five years later and the third
film that same year what so how does
this long-awaited sequel stack up to the
first film well
it's complicated uh what we are faced
with here is a fundamentally different
approach to adaptation that this movie
takes compared to the first and believe
it or not I actually think it's largely
for the better in some ways in some
areas this film still has a lot of
strange stuff for sure but largely I
think we're going in the right direction
so what do I mean when I say A
fundamentally different approach well
when I was watching the first film
amongst the absolute non-stop barrage of
bad acting CGI writing the whole nine
yards one element really stood out as a
huge issue that brought down everything
around it an element that this sequel
seemingly recognized and worked towards
improving and that element is tone
throughout the entirety of the first
film I just could not get over how dire
and depressing everything was Full Metal
Alchemist is certainly a work of fiction
that never shied away from tackling
Dakar motifs or sifting around the
minutia of a character's horrific inner
monologue but what is extremely
important to remember is that it was not
a depressing work arakawa worked very
hard to maintain a very specific tone
one that focused on the optimism
persistence and oftentimes outright joy
of the Elric Brothers as they trudged
through the harsh set of circumstances
set around them that balance is deeply
important we don't weep seeing Ed react
to Nina becoming a chimera just because
it's sad though it certainly is we weep
in large part because we are seeing this
genuinely joyful and persistent
character completely stopped in his
tracks brought to his knees and crushed
it is contrast that makes a tragedy
worthwhile not just sadness and that is
just something that the first film
didn't seem to understand amongst other
baffling things and while Movie 2 still
has issues good Lord does it still have
is its use I mean if this movie was a
person they'd be committed but however
despite that it's clear that this sequel
at the very least remembered that there
are more than 2 two emotions characters
can portray and the difference is
immediately apparent it isn't but
seconds into the movie that we are
greeted with a very different tone after
a very brief intro of Scar who I'm sorry
wait is that Ryan Higa I mean obviously
it's not clearly it's not but in the
right light and the right angle with the
hair scar looks like Ryan Higa during
his stint as a K-pop Star don't believe
me look at these pictures say it looks
at the same person after that intro we
fast forward to L and Al hopping onto a
train to Central City and are introduced
to the newcomer Ling by way of now I'm
gonna be honest seeing an actual
real-life human person splayed out on
the floor like that it got it got a
giggle at me and check it out I'm
laughing at this movie for something
funny they did on purpose literally the
first time that's happened Ed and Al's
entire interaction with Ling and Co are
wonderfully Breezy compared to the
depressing slog of the previous film
scenes and I also have to say the
casting for this entire group is on
point even as early as the first movie
the cast second costume design has
consistently been a solid part of these
films and I was glad to see that still
holding true it's even improved a bit
now as Ed's hair no longer looks like
the least convincing wig ever created
unfortunately there is very evidently a
difference between onset visual design
and what happens in post and whatever
happened in post for this movie well
I'll get to that in just a little second
now based on my praise of this movie's
tone and design so far you might get the
impression that I think the sequel could
possibly qualify as a good movie in some
small way and you'd be right I am of
course joking that is wrong if you
believe me then you need to take a long
hard look at yourself in the mirror and
then like and subscribe and watch this
video okay you get the point even though
this film lands on a more faithful tone
than its predecessor that does not
magically fix a complete lack of
character writing coherent visual
direction or the abundance of sheer plot
Insanity that takes place here even two
movies deep now the writing for these
still struggles to deliver any sort of
compelling character beats for a very
wide array of different personalities
and the hilarious thing is you might be
thinking damn live-action sure does ruin
anime and the thing is 99 of problems
with this film have nothing to do with
the format ironically enough during this
live-action film into an animated
production wooden change very much at
all I mean I've spent over four hours
with movie Al at this point and I feel
more familiar with the cashier lady at
my grocery store shout out Mary and time
and time again this movie tends to
Sprint through important character
development because it simply doesn't
have time to establish what are the
fundamentals of Storytelling making for
a bad story shockingly enough it has
nothing to do with the medium like take
this for example after some wacky action
on the train with Ed and Lang a land fan
blows up the train weren't they just
trying to get information about
immortality and the Philosopher's Stone
from it it seems like such a weird and
extreme thing to do that just doesn't
track at all with the internal logic of
the scene but I guess when you have just
a couple of minutes to introduce these
characters establish their goals stage a
train Heist and then derail the train
literally I guess consistent character
writing just kind of naturally goes off
the rails
oh
I'm very sorry for that so after over
two hours of non-existing on screen
previously we are finally introduced to
president Bradley and honestly he looks
pretty sick too casting once again spot
on and while Bradley is chilling and
looking all important the military guys
behind him can seem to restrain an
already restrained tied up group of bad
guys what is going on okay I have to say
this pause what the hell is with these
guards and soldiers they just absolutely
suck they suck hard and you will see
that it becomes a bit of a trend in this
film I'm not going to get into it too
much but they just [__] up so much in
this film anyways Ed and out are very
very quickly briefed on the scarra
situation and then they take off into
the city alone because I guess that's
just how they roll they then immediately
stumble upon Mei once again I will
humbly admit that uh it got a bit of a
laugh out of me seeing her split out of
the ground like that and as soon as May
is resuscitated and fed Ed ends up
chasing after her for totally legitimate
reasons I don't know and would you know
it she happens to run directly into our
old pal scar I mean like immediately run
directly to him by pure coincidence and
wouldn't you know it at the very same
time a random Soldier just so happens to
be yelling Ed's full legal name and
title within earshot of Scar so that he
can now know that Ed is an alchemist I I
really wish I was making all of this up
it's hard to imagine how something this
ridiculous and amateurish made its way
through a real-life writer's room like
someone read this and thought yep that
looks good let's print that now I'll
spell you the details of the CG Fight
Fest that ensues later on but the
scarify does the most and I do mean the
most important thing in this entire
movie's run time and that is introduce
live action Armstrong folks I won't
mince words with you not only is
Armstrong the funniest [__] thing I
have seen all week but I'm going to go
go so far as to say that his character
design is the perfect microcosm of this
film's entire approach if you want to
understand this movie just look at his
weird head like on the one hand I don't
think anyone can knock the way this
person looks as being inaccurate to the
character he's based on that certainly
is Armstrong I mean it quite literally
cannot be anyone or anything else in
fact the vast majority of this movie is
deeply invested in honoring its source
to its dying breath it's dying gasping
mutilated breath Armstrong looking like
that character splayed out on the ground
Ed literally shaking when being called
short even all the wacky silliness of Ed
trying to lure scar out later on the
entire movie is completely on a bash it
in his dedication to its anime Source
material and that is both a good thing
and a horrible thing on the one hand I
think it's important to retain the
element of the work that made it so
successful in the first place so often
anime or video game live-action movie
adaptations are almost embarrassed of
their Origins and tend to adapt
themselves so far away from their Source
material that the soul of their work is
completely lost in translation and
that's obviously not good but on the
other hand it it might be just as bad to
completely ignore the strengths and more
importantly weaknesses of a given medium
when creating an adaptation Neil
druckman creator of The Last of Us like
I mentioned before recognize this very
fact when working on creating the live
action adaptation of his game while
mowing down hordes of zombies is super
fun and totally works in a video game
context watching a real life human being
mow down dozens of zombies and kill and
mutilate hundreds of just way too many
like living people is deeply unhinged
and to that same end so many of the
Tendencies and tropes of anime just look
outright silly in this movie I'm
supposed to be emotionally engaged in a
tragic scene of Armstrong holding a
literal dead body of a deceased child on
the battlefield but I mean just look at
him all I do is in real life out loud
laugh at this and I'm assuming that's
not what they're going for here so all
in all I think the more lighthearted an
anime approach this movie took is
actually a net positive but it is only a
net positive because the first movie was
so deeply unenjoyable to begin with with
this second movie I might still not give
a single [__] about almost every single
emotional beat or character in its given
run time but at least I'm having a good
laugh along the way right
anyway and head back to pinnacle's place
for repairs and we cram a whole lot of
different plot elements and moments into
this tiny trip now sporting her iconic
outfit this time around which means I am
once again subject to the sadistic
torture that is watching her and Ed
flirt please God make them stop this
LARP scene right now at the same time we
also crime in hohenheim reuniting with
Ed in his trip and while I must once
again give it up for some pretty stellar
casting and costume design for HoHo I
still can't escape the feeling that so
many of the character motivations in
this series are completely and utterly
yada yadded away Into Obscurity the
passing and failed resurrection of the
ellorics mother still feels like a total
footnote and when the central motivation
and inciting incident of your story
feels like that that's when you know
your screenplay has failed now of course
in keeping with the same Spirit as soon
as Ed is all fixed up he heads straight
to the desert ishval land because well I
don't know why it's never already
explained the film just deal with it I
mean you've seen the anime right so you
know why he's there is that good enough
not really but we gotta move on at one
metric unit of exposition later and Ed
is all caught up on the history of Scar
and The Rock bells and takes off back to
Central City what a quick and so very
unexplained detour like it really makes
me wish I hadn't seen or read the
original series before this because I
feel like watching this without any
context prior from the original material
would leave you so completely lost uh
but yeah anyway once there he runs into
Salem Bradley himself and oh God
Pride
little bastard there he is once there at
an hour meet up with Ling and Hachi plan
to lure out Scar and thus a humunculi to
capture and honestly the subsequent
sequence of Ed being friendly
neighborhood Alchemists might have
actually completely changed my tune on
live action head altogether it's all
very anime but in a way that is actually
kind of charming and endearing the
entire sequence and really the rest of
the movie by and large plays out almost
exactly like the manga Skyrock chases Ed
Ling owns the funky life has an
unfortunate run in with Bradley and
Winery walks in right in time to find
scar as the one that killed her parents
or something yeah it's all exactly what
you'd expect if you were familiar with
the story but one thing this sequence
does do that is completely unique is
managed to have an emotional moment land
the entire scene with Winery
contemplating shooting Scar and then Ed
jumping in front of her to stop her is
done so well it's it's almost disarming
and that's not a pawn here okay
disarming that upon this amp okay
whatever for about a brief moment as I
watched Ed trigger a powerful flashback
to Scar's brother defending him I almost
forgot how bad the rest of these films
are who snuck this actual film into my
anime live action parody in truth I find
it hard to quantify why this scene works
for me while every single other
emotional scene in the series fell flat
maybe it's the legitimately good
performances maybe it's the complete
lack of atrocious CG maybe it's
Maybelline whatever the case despite all
the odds it's probably the best scene in
the entire Series so far and it really
makes me wish the rest of the movie
would have reached these Heights rather
than being stuck in the proverbial bud
and speaking of the proverbial mind I
glanced over the single best visual
spectacle of the entire movie maybe in
all of Cinema history you see as they
were escaping the nefarious clutches of
President Bradley landfan resourcefully
throws a flashbang Grenada blind her Foe
and as the stock Adobe after effect
light effect Graces our screens we are
treated to Bradley throwing a sword at
the two with his PNG Powers just look at
it link clearly is not as amused by
Bradley's PNG power as I was because I
was inconsolably laughing I fell off my
chair I hurt myself this film hurt my
sides so bad from laughing that I'm now
gonna retroactively give both the first
film and this film certified 10 out of
10. I'm gonna register myself as a
critic on Rotten Tomatoes just so that
there's a registered critic that says
this film's a 5 out of 5 or 100 or
certified fresh I mean just look at this
okay okay where was I oh yeah gluttony
is on screen green and with the power of
some grenade no Jutsu Eden Co managed to
tie up gluttony just like the manga and
just as I mentioned before while this is
accurate to its source material it is
just really hard to get past how goofy
this looks in real life but honestly at
this point I have embraced it you go
Ling tossed the Blobby body sphere into
the booze of your car
at the same time scar is completely
neutralized by Hawkeye with her
impressive feat of shooting him with a
pistol uh that's all it took what about
the entire line of soldiers earlier with
the guns aimed at scar what happened to
them why didn't they shoot him they
could have he's just a guy that clearly
would have done the trick at this point
we hit a large 30 minute stretch of
content that is frankly hard to even
talk about I mean in part because it's
all covering the elements of the manga
with no to note accuracy but also in
part because it's just all sort of the
same fare if I describe one of the
scenes to you I would have described
them all to you from Land fans recovery
to teasing father to the entirety of the
Ishmael civil or flashback of which
received surprisingly sufficient runtime
it all just sort of begins to blend
together I am very well known amongst my
co-workers as someone that takes
extensive notes with consuming media for
this Channel and I only managed to take
one single note for this entire 30
minute segment and those notes were and
I quote blah blah blah blah blah boring
now I'm paraphrasing of course but you
get the picture the entire thing is one
amalgam's glop of largely poor film
making the writing is lackluster the
acting is unremarkable the character
beats they're not there character
interactions hand wave the CG is
atrocious but hilarious and in fact
almost the entirety of the Civil War
flashback takes place against a very
very unconvincing green screen I'm sure
it might sound like I'm just glassing
over all of this out of laziness or
maybe for the sake of time but it really
is just that the whole thing is
uninteresting I mean watch it for
yourself and tell me I'm wrong I
finished watching the movie less than
two hours ago and I'm already having to
recheck footage just to remember
literally anything of note in this
section and in the big picture that is
the largest sin of this entire film
because unlike the first movie which was
just so incredibly boring from start to
finish this sequel was at least
entertaining me up until this point it
lulled me into a false sense of security
it certainly wasn't a good movie but it
was kind of fun and kooky to watch but
now suddenly I'm back to being super
bored again causing me to check the time
marker in the movie to see how much time
is left before I can stop watching it
it's hard to imagine a more clear-cut
indicator of a movie's failure at that
point in any case at the end of it all
we find Ed once again standing off
against scar for some reason and the
fight is surprisingly anticlimactic scar
is still partially wounded from his very
traumatic pistol wound and so after a
good 20 seconds of getting tiny rocks
thrown at him he decides to pull his
favorite trick and Escape by destroying
the ground beneath him and being crushed
by the rubble I mean escaping below
safely and in a very normal natural way
that has no problems attached to it at
all except gasp Ed and Al were planning
for that all along and Al was waiting
for him below to trap him except double
gas sky was planning for their planning
of his plan and he actually destroyed
the whole building except triple gaps he
immediately gets distracted by Winery
walking up like a dog getting distracted
by a squirrel and Ed just simply runs up
up and kickson thankfully for the sake
of this movie's run time as well as my
sanity he lands from the kick with his
fighting arm perfectly positioned and
outstretched so that Ed can tie it up in
a neat little bow how cute and
thoughtful of him this gives Winery the
chance to have her heart to heart with
Scar and bandage him up just like in the
manga it's it's it's not great but it's
there and let's be fair it certainly is
one of the scenes of all time but on the
bright side after bandaging Scar the
movie makes sure we get the message of
the scene and has her parents a
provingly appear before her as ghostly
apparitions Return of the Jedi style my
mind is melting talking about this guy
seriously I mean I'm really not sure if
I'm going to make it to the end of this
Trilogy in one piece and yeah so
unfortunately since this is a Trilogy we
can't just resolve the story here I need
some sort of inciting incident for the
third movie to follow God save me so lo
and behold gluttony arrives scar
heroically saves her and the heroes
Escape at least until literally 10
seconds later where scar is
incapacitated
we are treated to one final once again
surprisingly short fight that culminates
in gluttony eating Ling Ed and envy via
the power of being the dumbest character
in the history of men and the movie
leaves off with our beloved hero stuck
in gluttony's stomach facing off against
the true Envy in all of its glory god it
looks horrible
look uh like I said before I actually do
think there is a decent amount to enjoy
in this film and unlike the first movie
a good chunk of it was actually on
purpose which is nice the casting set
design musical score costume design and
even a lot of the acting was very
enjoyable in one way or another and I
found myself largely entertained for at
least the first two thirds of the movie
but even at its best it was sort of an
ironic enjoyment and it almost can't be
Glee at seeing anime tropes and
sensibilities brought to life so
unabashedly and hilariously and at its
worst I was right back to throwing my
hands into the air in frustration as
nonsensical writing Allied itself as CG
so bad I thought I was watching food
fight my main hope above all is that
somehow the third movie upholds The
tonal improvements of this film while
also delivering a legitimate story with
actual stakes and character writing but
of course
well yeah
okay
[Music]